[Music]
this dude got some detail you see the
grill on here it look like a family
member
[Music]
I got a pretty cool collection of
plastic cards I mean I know you always
been a part of the culture I keep one
classic at a time what made you cut it
down to one
[Music]
yeah I know you from like Oak Town I'm
from Atlanta and I've always loved the
Cali culture now it's six fours and
hopping is that a la thing or is it a
Cali thing it's definitely West Coast
you know like in L.A it's prominent it's
always been you know the switches the
three-wheel motion the six
the six trays they'll try everything out
here and throw it up in the air and hop
it around up north
we got a whole culture of classic cars
where we get into the high performance
of it
okay my Mexican homies whatever whatever
they keep that hopping you
know what's up fam Two Chains Jimmy
humility is a real Pioneer with his
record label Rancho humildy on the side
he collects and fixes up the most
expensivest low riders you've ever seen
two chains brought his boys two short
and Nene here to show him the culture
that's the guy right here man
y'all Defenders right here man hey man
will you tell me more about what's going
on let me tell you it's about the low
rider culture man it's a beautiful thing
you grab these cars anywhere from a 58
to a 64 is like the most popular ones
okay and then you get The Bel-Airs the
55s the 56 the 57. you'll make a you'll
make a Bel Air Harper you just get that
just they they hopping belairs now what
yes sir I got a 57 Bill there I would
never let's talk about this Nomad
there's a 57 Nomad Bel Air Nomad Nomad
Bellaire look it up matching numbers
this car has a 350. got AC in it got 350
with AC in it
custom radiator the frame was custom
built just to take the power for from
the engine you know what I'm saying and
then I decided to cut this car when I
say Cutters I decided to add Hydraulics
Hydraulics when you say cut that means
High Drops that means
you got hydraulic low rider 101 today
man yeah first first class what's
something like this going for oh man
this right here I say it's probably in
the market for about a buck 80. okay
about 180 this is the whole top is all
hand line by line piece by piece real
car paint candy all the way in then you
got custom interior you got Custom
Sounds that cost more to paint the top
than the car I can't believe it's a the
price
you went gold
they call this one Gold Everything Gold
Everything and then these right here
yeah
they moved the hitch it was just open a
minute ago it's been there since the
fifth
all gold everything so this one also has
a 350 in it underneath whole hinges this
is the most valuable low rider the year
the 59 Impala convertible this is the
Big Daddy of all cars 59 not the 64. nah
because people say 64 in wraps I heard
nah
59 is a big daddy 59 took over the
business I'm not the 64. nah 59 uh so
what it is the 64. I mean this is
so this is a 59 there's a 59. you've
replaced all the Chrome well most of the
Chrome with gold you're giving the
chocolate Willy Wonka right yeah got the
chocolate cutter this is original
interior from that year but this color
we did all gold in here trunk has gold
the whole on the carrots this thing is
what 200 plus even if you didn't
customize it right yes sir Hollywood
Boulevard up and back lower they you
know they just started doing that again
for real so what it is is they Banning
the low riding cruising
Cruise
if you go down the street turn around
and come back it's called crucial it's
been banned since the 80s right even up
north what the hell how's everybody from
the hood from the neighborhood this is
not Caucasian man let's talk about it
let's talk about it short that's why I
got banned so if you go down the street
bust a U-turn come back they can yeah
real quick get a ticket for cruising for
cruising we out there cruising and we
still bumping Too Short we still bumping
snow we still bumping all the old school
and the new stuff that's out there music
is very necessary you can't you can't be
in one of these cars listening to some
some stuff that don't go with it
[Music]
this one here I got offered 280 I got
offered two eight in the street and it's
still sitting right here this one here
is a an expensive car man what yours did
that's beautiful that's a 59. that's a
59. so it's a 59 custom you see it all
go and this Rog so it's all original all
right well that's another one no no this
is the one I I like and I see this one's
got regular 15 inch tires these three
right here a million dollars right there
three oh yeah I mean a million plus
definitely put a Plus on that for real
bro no Rolls-Royce in sight I mean if
you're from Cali I don't think you want
Rolls Royce you wanna roll Low Rider
Mexican culture is more low rider than
anything I own 859s this man got 859
what I'm learning today
um the more rarest of the drop top
Chevrolet Impalas I always thought it
was 64 because a lot of the rappers
obviously put it in songs I had an
experience in the low ride my man Nene
where Nae Nae at he hit the switch too
hard or something I'm at a party minding
my own business you know I'm saying I
got my own driving service you know what
I'm saying I'm cooling
enter Nene one of my one of my good
friends and tattoo artists and Ty doll
dollar sign it was like a Grammy party
right it was a Grammy party you know
what I'm saying and so we're about to go
to another get down you know you know La
got to get down after get down yeah
party hop in there so I'm about to get
in my black car service and they don't
say no get it get in here with us you
know what I'm saying I'm like
I get in here like now you get in the
front so I don't know what to expect and
man we take off I had to brace myself in
there man because I was kind of
loosey-goosey at first and I thought
from seeing videos that it was supposed
to be cruising like what you talking
about this doing 80 miles
per hour and hit the switch and I was
like I look like I'm about to come out
the top of that mall like man it was one
of the craziest experiences in the world
I got out that I told him I
was not getting back in that
we flying too so I'm like
okay then he hit that and I and it come
this way wise right man I don't see no
seat belts all right ain't no seat belts
that's what I'm saying
this so cold
let me see something that
been took off the frame man he got the
frame and Grave bro yeah come on now
what
what y'all got too much time time is not
where they got too much up so you got to
get into there no ride with me man I I
ain't no way in the hell you can do me
like that that's money man here get a
feel out of it man I just told you my
terrible experience and you want to put
me in there as soon as you're sitting
there Jimmy go hit that switch on you
bro all you gotta do is give it a little
tap
be careful right here all right
[Music]
be careful though oh
yeah go go
one more there you go
you see it
how did you get these pictures on the
side bro we got on the inside look at
this panel right here I love this
artwork man man y'all got to really see
like this right here I'm getting out of
my bed left for sure I probably spent
about 200 on this one you spent 200 yes
sir and you won't sell it oh hell no no
you can't sell that no middle day what
that mean humble humble my name Jimmy
humble I own 859s this man got 859 that
I'm I'm humiliated oh hell yes
foreign